She appeared in Karin Nanase's nightmare pillow search
and played the role of a public figure.It must have been persuasive because she acted out her
own command.The
rumor spread and her name became a hot topic on the internet.And
Karin Nanase was the rumor.  That
's right, I opened this Kojin Nanase summary site.
I've been accusing you all this time.
This site was unnaturally showing off Nanase Kojin,
amplifying it.
You were making up public figures You tried to 100 every solution I offered All
my solutions were stone tools for public figures Concluding that ghosts were fakes was against your purpose
Even though I'm
trying to spread rumors more, I'm still strong even if I'm forced to go to
heaven
.
I've been saying from the beginning that I'm going to lie.If I'm a prince, I'll be so mercedes that I'll
become
lighthearted.There are gods and buddhas on top of this.For
those who believe in this lie, the site you're looking at right now is the
Kojin Nanase Incident.  Center